en proposant pour sa première
réalisation sa propre version de street
ball
l'acteur bradley cooper s'attaque à un
monument cette histoire d'amour et de
gloire entre une chanteuse débutante et
un chanteur déclinant a déjà été
racontée plusieurs fois au cinéma dont
une fois par george cukor frédéric avant
de parler du film qu'est ce qui selon
vous a fait de cette histoire une
légende hollywoodienne alors il faut
juste rappeler un petit peu ce qui s'est
passé à l'origine à l'origine c'est un
film de william wellman de 1937
c'est un film qui en fait raccord
raconter un peu l'histoire d'un acteur
qui était alcoolique était john
barrymore la diversion extrêmement
célèbres dont vous parlez que j'adore
avec de george cukor avec james mason et
julie guerlande et qui est un film on va
dire véritablement sur la tendresse dans
un couple mais également sur la vraiment
la mythologie hollywoodienne et la façon
dont hollywood peut décider un peu comme
à mont olympe qui va être élu et qui ne
sera pas élu qui va des skis la
descendre et qui va monter il ya une
version aussi en 1976 de personnes avec
barbra streisand et on va dire qu'ils
étaient plutôt un film sur la chute des
idées au rock des années 60 avec kris
kristofferson dans le rôle principal est
là donc évidemment on a repris cette
histoire dans un monde dans un univers
plus contemporain et dans l'histoire
vraiment des stars du rock bradley
cooper interprète ici le chanteur
pygmalion pour le premier rôle féminin
le réalisateur a choisi une débutante
qui n'a que cinq petits rôles à son
actif stefani germanotta plus connu sous
le nom de lady gaga superstar de la pop
il l'a même imposé à la production qui
n'est pas convaincu on va regarder les
images
oui
ouais comptes bancaires
[Musique]
oh
six co scénariste et réalisateur il
interprète le rôle principal en plus il
chante son playback on peut saluer quand
même le panache mari est ce qu'il a
réussi son pari mais carrément saluons
salon et celui de lady gaga qui a un
rôle très intéressant parce que c'est
l'histoire donc de cette espèce de
diamants bruts une fille qui écrit des
chansons qu'à plein de trucs à dire et
qui va se transformer en star et c'est
rigolo quand on pense à la carrière de
diva de lady gaga que moi je ne
connaissais que costumés pour comme pour
un carnaval qui est cette espèce de
figure flamboyante outrancière engagé en
même temps féministe enfin et là tout à
coup c'est son vrai visage celui d'une
fille
voilà me joly me quelconque une fille
normale on a envie de dire
dans cette séquence assez formidable
parce que tout le début du film est
formidable cette séquence se conclut
quand même par un flic qui lui dit un
gros mot qui la traitent de chez plus
quoi je le répèterai pas il lui colle
son poing dans la figure et je trouve
que c'est une réelle et une relecture
vraiment contemporaine pour le coût de
cette histoire et avenir d'eric partage
l'amour de marie ça se voit vraiment à
son visage dans ce cas là qu'est ce
qu'on fait cher pub et ben on fait un
duel alors rentrer
et c'est pas moi qui les demande est
révéré kaboul au nar j'aurais bien voulu
voir le film avec marie pour moi ça a
été un calvaire
ça a été véritablement des grands mots
non ça a été un calvaire
parce que tu parles de bradley cooper tu
parles de lady gaga tu dis que lady gaga
apporte une interprétation plus fraîches
parce qu'on découvre enfin son vrai
visage
moi je ne vois qu'un masque pendant tout
le film je sens vraiment qu'elle essaye
de jouer la fragilité elle est toujours
dans les mêmes poses de visage lui je
n'en parle même pas lui il a une
expression au visage dès le début il est
dans un cliché rock absolue c'est un
sale type avec sa bouteille de jack
daniels qui fait des solos de guitare on
ne sort pas d'une espèce de mythologie
rock un peu un peu un peu nauséabondes
tu dormais et non mais il ne change pas
et il ne changera pas son visage de tout
le film
il sera toujours figé dans comme une
espèce de statut de 6 alors il ya tout
tout ce début toute cette première
manche dis pas que le film est parfait
je dis pas banaliser un niveau d'avant
non mais toi en l'occurrence moi le
tuteur je n'ai pas revu depuis 30 ans et
j'en avais pas besoin le fou c'est par
un film qui m'avait actionnaires plus
que ça donne et non parce que tu peux
pas comparer tout à coup tu vois ce
serait le ce sera l un peu dégueulasse
pour pour bradley cooper et en
l'occurrence la première heure du film
est absolument formidable se rencontrent
comment ils se rencontrent dans une
boîte de drague de drag-queen drag
queens où elle où elle fait un numéro
incroyable de deux cabarets quoi où elle
reprend la vie en rose et c est lui qui
est une star pas du tout au bout du
rouleau et pas du tout jalouse qui est
injuste un type alcoolo voilà un cas
plus trop d'inspiration tombe amoureux
de cette fille est ce que j'aime
beaucoup dans le film d'abord des
grandes histoires d'amour au premier
degré hollywoodienne moi j'en vois pas
tant que ça mais c'est le problème du
film c'est que son axe c'est cette
histoire d'amour qui est quand même
désolant de bout en bout
j'ai vraiment eu l'impression de voix en
fait un film pour adolescents où tout
était lisse et de bout en bout sur les
personnages sur lui sur elle qu'est ce
que tu appelles lycée alors oui ça mal
lui en fait il est appelé il est il est
alcoolique on a compris on ne sait même
pas d'ailleurs très bien comment
commence sa chute dans le star system
c'est très mal raconté soudain long on
voit que ce type est passé de grands
concerts en et festival de rock à
quelques à des petites salles des
petites salles de fêtes il fait le grand
concert
non non on le voit un moment donné à
aller dans une espèce de festival pour
un truc médical ou je sais pas quoi le
24e 24ème congrès ou qu'ashton mais mon
mot malheureux avec ashton tout cas une
chute qui n'est pas racontée dans le
film elle arrive vraiment comme un
cheveu sur la soupe et tu disais tu
disais ce qui se passe dans l'histoire
dans l'histoire d'amour entre les deux
mois je les vois absolument pas évolué
pendant le film vraiment je les vois
figé des débuts dans un archétype et ils
vont nous parce qu'il n'y a pas vraiment
de cette d'interaction entre les deux
alors tu me dire il ya des scènes
musicales
effectivement il ya des scènes où il
chante tous les deux il n'y a pas de
scènes de vie alors je prendrai pas des
références anciennes tandis que ce
serait dégueulasse de faire ça et mais
il y avait au moins des scènes à un
moment donné où il se passait quelque
chose entre eux l'a simplement à part
chanter ils font rien en semble
évidemment à part s'est engueulé à la
fin je n'étais pas d'accord du tout à
fait et c'est d'une mauvaise foi folle
parce que juste avant le film le film
prend vraiment le temps de raconter tout
le début de leur histoire tout comment
ils vont tomber amoureux etc et ensuite
la métamorphose de l'héroïne elle est
vraiment raconter par le menu
as tu as raison tu as raison de parler
de ça parce que y'a une métamorphose de
l'hérault supprimant l transformer la
galicie vie tel est lé transformer a
effectivement elle est transformée par
l'industrie du spectacle
mais là à ce moment là il ya quelque
chose qui se tisse sur ce personnage que
le spectacle en fait et il n'en fais moi
vraiment je trouve qu'il n'en fait rien
c'est juste des pistes qui sont comme ça
évoqué dans le film il y aura même pas
une discussion il y aura même pas
quelque chose on va l'avoir transformé
une excuse alors on va tradition
d'arbitré l'idée un jour à dominer bari
4 qui m'étonne un peu denses que vice et
on va pas le comparer aux précédents
battus fait un remake c'est un peu quand
même la base on va te comparer au film
que tu que tu ris mais qui était déjà un
remake d'un remake bacon par barbara
stressante aussi je vais y avait ses
charmes
oui on peut le dire comme ça surtout
pour un premier film
moi je moi ce qui m'interroge c'est
pourquoi tu fais un film déjà un remake
pourtant pourtant visible sur valence en
parle d'un mythe
il ya un moment cette histoire là elle
est devenue un mythe donc soit on dit
qu'on montre plus jamais un mythe ni au
théâtre ni de cinéma suisse est là mais
coco il va falloir être très inventifs
pour trouver des sujets soit on dit
qu'on revisite les mythes et on peut le
faire avec talent et en proposer une
version contemporaine
de bradley cooper avec lui même et lady
gaga allez-y en fusée allez-y